hello everyone welcome to another
episode of Science and Technology q a
for kids and others and I see their a
bunch of questions that have come in
here and let's uh see how I can do with
them
let me see oh boy there's a question
here from blank asking why are there
both herbivores and carnivores it
doesn't isn't it evolutionarily best for
everything to be omnivorous
so it's like why why are there creatures
that eat only vegetables creatures that
eat only other creatures other animals
why shouldn't everything be set up like
us humans are where we have um
their capability to both eat meat and
vegetable material that's why we have
both grinding teeth and pointy canine
dog-like teeth and so on I I don't
specifically know the answer and one
thing that tends to happen in these
evolutionary explanations is that things
developed in the way they developed in
the course of biological evolution then
we look at the answer and then we come
up with some explanation for why it had
to be that way and sometimes it's a bit
of a put up job what answer one comes up
with but I would say the following thing
in general which is
that
if you want to be a creature that both
you know swims in the sea flies in the
air you know Waddles up mountains and
things like that you've got to have this
whole collection of different kinds of
apparatus to do that
and that's complicated to arrange
and it usually is the case that the more
specialized the creature is the more
likely it is to be successful and the
way it shouldn't you know if if the
creature adds a tail because that's a
convenient thing to do for some very uh
special thing that it does but sometimes
the tail gets stuck when it's doing
something else and the poor creature is
killed because its tail got stuck and
some other animal ate it or some such
other thing so you know typically having
additional capabilities in the case of
biological evolution tends to add sort
of cost to a biological organism things
can go wrong if you have that extra
little thing sticking out somewhere you
know it can get infected or it can
things can happen to it and if you're
just the Sleek simple I just do what I
do and I'm specialized and the thing I
do works out it's all good now of course
the problem with where it's very
specialized is if things change in the
environment you're in or something like
that and the specialized thing you were
doing no longer makes sense or no longer
works out then your toast and then the
generalist organism tends to do better I
mean the big sort of meta discovery of
organisms was the ability to learn that
is there was you know and presumably
many early organisms sort of their
capability to do what they did was
determine genetically the thing had
these you know these legs and all it
knew how to do with those legs was this
and then increasingly
organisms started to be able to learn
during their lifetime that is even if
they had this set of legs which were
sort of normally intended to do this
well actually the organism could learn
that you could do something different
with those legs and so it was less
fragile less determined how it was going
to work and what it was going to do
based on Purely on the way that it was
sort of physiologically constructed you
know I would say that the um it's sort
of interesting this question about
specialization versus generalization and
when when specialization is the right
strategy when it isn't depends a bit on
the environment depends on a bit how on
how changing the environment is you know
we can ask the same thing for technology
is when is it better to be special
purpose versus general purpose I think
that again it depends on what you're
trying to do I mean this is a an issue
we see uh talk about for example
computers there was a time before people
understood about general purpose
computers before people understood about
the idea of programming a computer to do
different kinds of things when people
imagined that you had to have different
Hardware built computers for different
functions and that turned out to be not
such a great idea because the idea of
making a general purpose computer is an
idea that has great economy of scale
that is you just have to make that one
kind of microprocessor you make zillions
of them and you make them very very
efficient and then for each particular
function you want the computer to do you
just have to add software now I suppose
that one could think about this for
brains as well there is a one can
imagine and in fact this was certainly
true of lower organisms that they're a
special purpose brains that just do
particular things and then there are us
humans that have at least as far as
we're concerned fairly general purpose
brains that we can kind of learn all
sorts of different things with and that
turns out to be at least an hour because
ecological niche a good idea I mean
again in this question about
generalization versus specialization one
could certainly imagine a situation
where having that um uh you know that
big brain that can do ever all sorts of
different kinds of things would actually
be a negative for the survival of the
species it could be that the better
thing to do is just have those species
be pure drones that just do what they do
and don't have them think too much
because if they think too much they'll
go off and do other random things and
get themselves in trouble I mean sadly
there are certainly situations in human
society where I think that's uh uh
that's kind of um that tends to be the
uh you know just have the people do what
you wanted them to do so to speak and
don't have them think too much for
themselves
um I think that's an unfortunate uh
place to be but but that's something
that that can happen so in any case I I
think I'm I'm sort of uh diverging quite
a bit from the original question about
carnivores and herbivores but um I think
this General no point about when is it
better to be specialized for a
particular purpose when is it better to
have have this capability of
generalization uh you know I think
that's the trade-off one's talking about
and I think in in many places in
biological evolution
specialist wins and it's uh but but not
all places and it's an interesting
question as um uh what aspects of um of
of kind of the environment and so on
affect
um
whether the the generalist will win or
the specialist will win so to speak
um and uh uh I think the the history of
life on Earth insofar as you know we're
the we're the top species right now uh
the generalists seem to be winning since
since that's kind of where we are in the
in the in the chain of species so to
speak
all right let's see
uh
let's see
huh okay this is a specific comment from
Michael here about
um uh saying short digestive systems are
better for meters they offer some
protection from infection but a less
sufficient for extracting nutrients from
plant matter
a fire allowed us to enjoy both worlds
that's interesting it's an interesting
point yeah I can see that as being the
case that there are there are Critters
that you know like uh I don't know cows
and things that have you know the
multi-stomic you know let's take some
grass and extract something from it
um whereas you know the meat is all
ready to be um uh to be consumed and the
proteins are all all ready to be uh
um
um
to be taken okay we have another comment
here from Steve aren't we specialists in
terms of our ability to think
interesting
you know
the thing that um
okay so there's a question of What kinds
of things
can one imagine happening in the world
so to speak
so if we believe that the world operates
according to certain rules
certain natural laws let's say what
kinds of things might be in those
natural laws
and can we can we find a way to
represent how how well what kinds of
things can be in those natural laws
that's one sort of basis for how General
are things well one of the things that's
come out of for example our physics
project and came out a bit from earlier
work of mine is this idea that the
things that we now know that we can set
up in computers the kinds of operations
that computers do the kinds of things
that a general purpose computer can do
seem to cover really well the kinds of
things that our physical Universe can do
so we could say well there might be
other things that our physical Universe
can't do and our computers can't do
and those are things that indeed are not
captured by things in our physical
universe but now we can ask when we look
at things that we do with our brains to
what extent can we successfully capture
the things that are going on that are
possible in principle in our universe or
possible in principle with computational
systems and I think at least to the
theoretical level that we are covering
pretty well with our brains and with the
kinds of operations that we can do with
our brains we are covering the general
category of things you can do with
computation so for example it is
although we may not be super fast at it
we can in principle follow through the
kinds of operations that our physical
world does to do what it does the
physical world is doing it much faster
than our brains do it but we can we're
not like oh my gosh you know we don't we
can't conceptualize anything that's even
vaguely like the way the physical world
works at least that's the the impression
we have and so you know this question of
whether
whether our brains are so so I think
it's sort of a core basic level that the
things we can do with our brains are the
same as the kinds of computational
things that can be done in the physical
Universe now if you can ask if you ask
the question can we do it easily or not
that's a whole different question
and the story of kind of the development
of Science and things like that has been
to take kind of the raw material of what
we can do with our brains and build
these kind of Stepping Stones these
these sort of towers that allow us to
get to a higher level and and then work
from that level so for example when we
invent mathematics and mathematical
notation we're inventing something which
can be implemented in our kind of brain
level Hardware but once we have the idea
of mathematical notation we've jumped
much further we've made use of sort of
discoveries of humans we've learned from
that and now we can sort of operate with
our same sort of brain Hardware we can
do more sophisticated things I like to
think that my kind of Life work of
developing computational language
finding a way to sort of represent the
world in sort of computational terms is
providing us another level of kind of
Step Up in terms of what we can we can
operate with with our brains we can
think in terms of computational language
if we learn wolfen language or whatever
you can you can start to think in terms
of computational language and you get to
be able to conceptualize things that if
you were just left kind of to the raw
brain without any of that learning you
wouldn't be able to do
so there's sort of a question of are
there modes of thinking that we haven't
yet encountered which once we get it
once we get that idea we'll be able to
start thinking about all sorts of things
and all sorts of all sorts of terrific
ways I would say the best example of
that in in the last 100 years or so is
this idea of computation before the
notion of of general purpose computation
the notion of well all the things that
come with that the sort of symbolic
representation of the world the kind of
the idea of rules that operate on rules
and all sorts of things like this before
those Notions were known it was very
hard for people to think in in those
kinds of terms and there was definitely
a a a block in what could be
conceptualized what could be kind of
Imagine for purposes of science or
purposes of kind of General intellectual
rational thinking so you know as we move
forward and we learn more and we sort of
build this sort of taller Tower of
abstract Concepts and so on yes we will
start to be able to think in different
kinds of ways I mean that's the that's
that's typically sort of the the notion
of a paradigm the notion of a new way to
think about things that's all about
having this kind of new uh new domain in
which you can kind of conceptualize new
sorts of things and you know if we look
over the history of the development of
science for example we see a variety of
stages of kind of new conceptualizations
of things so you know I think that the
sequence that I've been sort of
identifying in recent times is you know
back in Antiquity a couple of thousand
years ago the big question was what's
stuff made of and I don't know who first
started to ask that maybe nobody cared
that you know you look at these
different things the Rocks the plants
the the the ocean whatever else and
maybe nobody had really cared what is
this made of and is there some
commonality and what these things are
made of maybe nobody had really they say
you know there's a there's a plant
there's an animal it does what it does
we don't really care how it's what it's
built up from but people started asking
that question and people started
thinking about things in terms of what
that individual small component parts
were and often realizing that they were
the same component parts repeated in
many different kinds of systems and that
was you know for a long time that was
sort of what the the science or the
early sort of uh pre versions of science
looked like then 1600s the big sort of
thing that came in was the idea of let's
use mathematics to describe the natural
world and write formulas for how things
work in the world that's another
different level of thinking about things
and there were Concepts introduced like
things like energy and well that was a
little bit later but Force momentum
things like this which become Concepts
that give you ways to think about the
world that people hadn't really
conceptualized before that
you know I think in in my own sort of
Lifetime the the um uh the the that big
thing was sort of this idea of
computation and this I mean that that
that fundamental idea goes back about
100 years
um but sort of its application to
thinking about the world in general as
opposed to just thinking about kind of
mathematics for example that's a much
more recent idea of more like 1980s
um type time scale
um of uh of kind of conceptualizing
things that way and starting to reason
about the world in terms of computation
so I think that's that's kind of the um
uh the sense in which um uh uh we we
gradually get different places that we
reach in terms of our ability to think
about things different paradigms for
thinking about things in in recent times
for me this whole multi-computational
Paradigm is uh sort of a yet a new way
of thinking about things and I I don't
doubt and in fact I think it's an
inevitable feature of what we know about
the fun fundamental Constitution the
computational structure of the world
that there will always be new abstract
ways of thinking about things there's
never going to be an end to sort of uh
sort of ways to conceptualize lumps of
of knowledge
um and one will always be able to sort
of build more and more pieces of the
tower now the question for us humans is
we build that piece of the tower we say
well in principle now we can understand
this or that thing it could be the case
that we just don't care that the nature
of humans what humans are interested in
human society it's like well yes in
principle you could study this area of
abstract mathematical kinds of things
but actually just nobody cares about it
and it's something where yes you could
study it but we're not going to and
that's a that's a complicated Loop
between what we humans want to do and
care about doing and what is possible to
do I mean I certainly know there are
areas of science ones I've been
interested in particularly one area is
the area of ruiology this question of
kind of when you have a simple
computational rule what consequences
does it have and often the big Discovery
I made in the 1980s is that even with
very simple rules you can have very
complicated Behavior and the question
then is so what and the answer is in
some cases well the so what is it's
connected to things we see in nature
it's connected to things we want to
build in technology but there's a large
class of cases where you put down a
simple rule it does a complicated thing
you look at it you say that's quite
intra I think that's interesting but
it's not clear that that's yet a thing
where lots of people think it's
interesting so it's something where you
can in principle do it and it's not yet
a thing where people say oh yeah yeah
that's the thing we should do
so you know that that's kind of the the
the loop that happens there can be a way
of thinking about things that is in
principle possible but nobody cares at
least not for 100 years 200 years
whatever and then suddenly there's a
reason why Human Society starts saying
yes we really really care about that you
know this is the way to make sort of
customized art where every piece of art
looks different every time we look at it
or something and that that becomes a
really important thing and then then
suddenly what was this kind of obscure
sort of uh tendril of how one thinks
about things becomes much more
mainstream
boy you guys are asking uh commenting
about things about biology I don't know
are many of these comments about uh
don't don't we have lower amounts of
stomach acid than carnivores do I do not
know sounds reasonable to me
um
let's see
uh
let me look at some other things here
um
the question here about robotics asking
what's holding back robotics why don't
we have humanoid robots yet
um
you know what often holds back robots is
very mundane stuff for example one thing
is uh purely you have joints and our way
of having actin filaments and our
muscles and things like that pretty
efficient
often one of the things and and I I
noticed this when I see humanoid robots
the thing you really got to look at is
what comes out of the back of the robot
how thick is the wire how much power is
going into that robot to actually move
its joints around and do the things it
does there's a lot of kind of
um well I wouldn't say smoke and mirrors
but um there's a lot of kind of strange
trickery that often goes on in humanoid
robots a lot of issues that have been
difficult to resolve that are very kind
of mundane like just you need a lot of
power to drive those joints or you know
for example for us humans our legs go
you know we have we have a locked state
where our knees are locked and it's hard
to do the the robot motion planning when
you can get to that locked State and so
people a common thing I think is less
true now but maybe 10 years ago it
tended to be the case you'd see human
old robot and it would always be a
little bit its knees were as a little
bit bent because it was too difficult to
do the the sort of motion planning of
how do you get the robot to this
location when you had that kind of
locking possibility I think that the um
I think there are both practical aspects
of kind of the uh you know Motors and
actuators and how good they are and
things like this I think there's a
different thing which is uh
it's kind of the the trade-off that one
often sees between technology and
biology
you know if your goal is to make a
flying creature
people back 120 years ago something like
that 100 and more than that now 140
years ago whatever you know we're
convinced that the way you would make
something that would fly us to Flap
wings
um because that's what they saw Birds
doing but it turns out that when it
comes to the materials and control
systems that we readily have flapping
wings is a pretty bad idea and there
aren't airplanes that flap Wings on
purpose so to speak
um that's a great for Birds bad for
planes
so in the case of Robotics one of the
questions is things which are
biologically convenient given the actual
things we have of you know actin fibers
and muscles and tendons and all this
kind of thing uh to what extent is that
something that when we are building
technological systems which don't have
those same components
um to what extent should we really be
following exactly what the biology has
done now one of the things about
humanoid robots that's tricky is that
we've built an environment that's really
pretty good for us bipeds of you know
that are roughly you know a meter and a
half tall or whatever else it is and
that they have arms and have opposable
thumbs and all kinds of things like this
we've built the world
uh so that we can manipulate it well
so you can say well I want to make a
robot that just has wheels and it has a
you know one kind of grabbing you know
uh sort of uh scoop or something like
this and it's like well that's nice but
the world that we've built that's all
around us is really optimized for us us
humans with our detailed sort of way of
of grabbing things and walking around
and so on and so that's kind of a big
motivation to build humanoid type robots
is we get to leverage we get to exist in
the same sort of built environment that
us humans have and that's that that's
something so that's a reason to go
humanoid so to speak in the structure of
robots even if it's actually very
awkward in terms of the materials that
we have available in terms of building
robots
you know my own suspicion about robotics
which uh is that the one of the issues
is that we've tended to make robotics
very special purpose you know I haven't
been to a robot trade show robotics
trade show in a maybe five years maybe
more but it certainly used to be the
case that you'd go to a a big trade show
about Robotics and you literally there'd
be an aisle about about hands they've
been aisle about you know legs there'd
be each different part of a sort of
robot there would be different Hardware
different devices different structures
that were being set up for those
different um uh
for those different uh sort of pieces of
of the robot now with computers that's
not what we have we have general purpose
computers we have computers where you
have a particular computer and then it's
merely a matter of programming to get it
to do all these different things now
with industrial robots there's a little
bit of this you know you have one big
arm and you can program it in different
ways to do different things but we're
not at the point with robots where you
can have sort of a a general purpose
mobile walk around type robot that can
be like programmed to do very different
kinds of things and I've often thought
that the The Way Forward is to construct
a robot in a way it's very different
from the way biology does it to have
something that consists of lots of
identical components and where you have
some complicated thing where all those
little components are shifting around
relative to each other and you have this
kind of uh thing which is like a bunch
of little sugar cubes or something and
they're all sliding relative to each
other and changing the shape of the
robot so to speak years ago I tried to
build some of those kinds of things that
turned out to be difficult for very
practical reasons about the difficulty
of just getting enough force and enough
ability to deliver power to things to
move stuff around I actually think some
of those issues have now somewhat been
solved and it might be time to look at
general purpose robotics again
um and and probably there are some
different mechanical ideas about how to
do it but the question is really can you
make a structure that is really a truly
general purpose robot where it's all
turned into software where it's no
longer oh we have to have a specific you
know are we going to have this kind of
grabbing hand or that kind of grabbing
hand where it's purely the structure is
dynamically built uh sort of at run time
at the time when the robot is doing its
things
um and uh it's all sort of determined by
by software now you know having talked
about determining things by software
there are plenty of problems in robotics
that even with the software capabilities
we have today they're really hard like
you know a typical one is the the the
picking problem you know if you've got
uh let's say a problem of great
practical importance for um you know big
uh big online retailers and things where
they've got a giant Warehouse full of
millions of kinds of things people want
to buy and those things are all
different shapes and it's like can you
pick them and put them in a box and um
the answer is that's actually pretty
hard and notably the things that people
make are typically if you're a
manufacturer of a thing and that thing
is unpickable up by a human it's
probably a bad thing it's it's probably
not a a realistic uh
um uh you know it's probably something
that's not going to be convenient in the
world so probably you make things which
are somehow pickable up by humans but to
make them also pickable up by robots is
a different problem and the problem of
making a robot that will do a good job
of doing sort of human-like picking up
of things has proven to be very hard and
that that's you know both like how much
force do you put do you crush the egg or
do you not crush the egg does the thing
kind of slide out of your hand you know
what do you do
Etc et cetera et cetera this has turned
out to be hard so you know there are
there are issues like that that are that
are already around
let's see
uh
yeah comments uh I see comments about
um uh neural Nets and learning
algorithms finding approximate solutions
to problems in robotics yeah that's
certainly the case I mean a very common
issue in robotics is you want to uh you
know take your finger and touch your
nose or whatever you've got to figure
out how to run those Motors in your you
know in your arm to move your hand so
that you bring your finger to your nose
or whatever if you're a robot with a
nose
um and uh that problem of I guess
inverse kinematics is is a problem
actually people have done a lot of work
in with algebraic computation a lot of
things using our software technology to
to try and solve those problems by by
understanding the kind of equations of
motion of things and being able to
invert them and kind of solve for how do
we get to this position
I think there's sort of a new generation
of those kinds of capabilities which
have been built using machine learning
kinds of systems
um I think a a pretty common idea I
don't know how well it really really
works is this sort of reinforcement
learning idea where you're kind of um
you see what happens in the world and
you can't you kind of you probe the
world you say what if I put my hand here
well then you say this happens okay
that's feedback then um uh
um
uh then then we sort of learn from that
now in in in the theory of control
systems there's been for for many
decades kind of a um uh
oh gosh what is it called well it's not
feedback control it's a more General
version of that that is the same kind of
Technology as reinforcement learning
um in both cases it's developed uh using
using somewhat the same internal
technology the big issue tends to be
what's your kind of model of the world
what's the model that you are trying to
learn against that says how things work
and that you're trying to tweak to
actually get the system to do what you
want
but yeah I think that that's um I mean
you know there is definitely progress
being made I I would not say that it's
sort of uh blowing everything out of the
park
um at least based on the things I've
seen
um the the a lot of kind of the the
problems of um I mean there's definitely
been progress made for example in
Machine Vision the dramatic progress a
decade ago from uh really it was very
hard to recognize objects and to
teleport you know the five or ten
thousand kinds of picturable nouns that
we have in English what is this thing
that we are looking at
um that with kind of uh you know this
was one of the surprise uh discoveries
of deep learning neural Nets was if you
bash the thing hard enough and train it
long enough you can have it actually
make the correct distinctions between 10
000 kinds of objects and and and
recognize those sorts of things
um but there's uh you know the progress
on on sort of more subtle issues is is
it's it's it's going but it's definitely
not you know it didn't just suddenly
arrive and now it's all solved
um
let's see
uh
comments questions here about
bioelectricity which is something I
don't know much about
um but I mean I know tiny amounts about
it it's um uh
you know there's in a sense there's when
we grow
what are the signals that determine how
tissues and organs and things grow and
some of those signals are known to be
chemical signals often quite small
molecules that can diffuse through other
other pieces of tissue and kind of their
concentrations Define sort of should we
grow in this direction or that
um sometimes there are more uh actual
contact kinds of things of oh you hit
another piece of of of of tissue don't
grow anymore and I think there's decent
there's there's decent evidence that
electrical processes can also affect uh
kind of um
the way things grow
um I I think uh you know the the um the
thing that um I mean one of the things
about biology
is a little bit like technology
it uses everything
so you know if there's a mechanism you
know if there's some mechanism that
involves using uh little
Atomic magnetic moments to sense
magnetic fields if there's a mechanism
that involves using some Optical effect
in here or there
there's a good chance that somewhere
biology will have used it just like
there's a good chance that somewhere in
technology somebody will have used that
effect once discovered so to speak now
some some things biology finds it hard
to get access to like there aren't a lot
of Wheels there are occasional ones you
know a bacteria you know there are
bacteria with flagella that kind of go
around and um that are sort of driven
round like wheels and so on but on large
scales you don't see a lot of wheeled uh
animals and things uh and um so there
are things which for one reason or
another biology has a bit of a hard time
accessing but generally if there's a
mechanism biology will typically
somewhere make use of it and then the
question is often well how important is
the use that it makes and that can be a
feature you know when we ask about I
don't know physiological medical effects
of things it's like well you know how
important is the our electromagnetic
fields on affecting biological organisms
no doubt there is an effect
is it an important effect is it an
effect that's going to uh sort of uh you
know kill us all off is it an effect
that's going to make us all get smarter
is it you know what's the is it a
significant effect is it not a
significant effect that's a much harder
thing to assess
I think um
uh
that there's a question here about from
glitch about thoughts about computer
designed organisms
um
well I mean we
we don't yet have the um the uh the
capability to do that I mean what uh you
know we we can create uh you know and
and it's increasingly straightforward to
do Gene editing to edit the DNA of
organisms and make a different organism
by changing the DNA
knowing what consequences that will have
is really hard I mean we don't know if
you just show me a a piece of DNA and
say what's this going to do that's a
difficult thing to figure out the very
first level of that is from the DNA from
the original uh base pair sequence on
the DNA one is defining the sequence of
amino acids that will be used to
construct a protein one of the things
that got significantly easier in the
last few years is knowing given that
sequence of proteins sequence of amino
acids in a protein let's say you know
100 100 000 amino acids or something uh
in a in a sequence in a line in A
protein that protein is going to curl
itself up into some shape and that shape
is determined by the sequence of amino
acids and the question of exactly what
shape is the protein going to wind up in
is something that was very hard to
figure out computationally it's become
in the last few years it's through
machine learning kinds of things and and
a lot of just ingestion of data
from existing knowledge of of how
proteins get folded up it's become much
more straightforward to know how will
the protein fold itself up and and it's
important to know that because a lot of
the operation of proteins and biology is
associated with the actual physical
fitting of one protein into another or
things like you know I don't know the
the hemoglobin in our blood It's A
protein that happens to have a little
little hole in the middle of protein
that's just the right size to fit an
iron atom and so a hemoglobin picks up
iron atoms and that's how we transport
oxygen around around through our blood
and that's just one example of a zillion
mechanisms you know our our muscles have
what triple helix helices I guess which
are which are used which are again
proteins that um can be extended and not
um under electrical effects and I think
the um
uh protein the general idea protein is a
very flexible material for making things
out of it's what we're com we're made
out of basically and we can now so the
specification of make a protein well we
can do that the question then is first
question is well well if you just write
down a random DNA sequence what kind of
protein will that make it's been
something I've been curious about for a
long time if you just write random DNA
sequences down forget biological
evolution just pick proteins at random
what will they be like will they be
useful will they not be useful I don't
think we really know I think there is a
certain sense in which probably given a
protein which is a certain shape biology
may find a use for that protein more so
than biology kind of scratching its head
and saying what shape of protein should
I make now there are places where making
random proteins is done in biology
immune system the Adaptive immune system
is all about making random proteins
basically you're making in antibodies
for example they're you know we make 10
billion different kinds of antibodies
that are made at random as little short
sequences of a protein basically and and
those different short sequences make the
antibodies be different shapes and those
different shapes are shapes that that
will attach to different kinds of of
antigens different kinds of of things
that might infect us so to speak so you
know we we're kind of a little bit onto
the the make a random protein kind of
idea that's how the immune system works
but in terms of the the technology of
make a random protein and see how it be
useful that's not something we're doing
at this point and in terms of the
designer protein idea of you know let's
you know let's kind of make something
where we design the protein where we
specify the sequence to make a protein
that's a certain shape that's just
becoming it it's because of advances in
sort of computationally determining the
shapes of proteins one's just starting
to see serious work being done on we've
got this shape we want to achieve now
let's make a protein that
forms into that shape and I think we're
in very very early days of knowing what
kinds of shapes will be care about you
know we could imagine making all sorts
of micro machines that would do all
sorts of interesting things outer
proteins
um but I don't think it's been well
conceptualized what kinds of shapes of
proteins one would like to make and and
now as of very recently it becomes
somewhat possible to see how one would
construct such a protein so in terms of
sort of computer designed organisms
that's kind of I think the Leading Edge
and it's very recent Leading Edge of
sort of the designer protein now people
tried 20 years 20 30 years ago now with
design of drugs so drugs are off and
sometimes they're small molecules but
sometimes they're proteins or bigger
molecules and the uh one one wants to
have a drug you know the usual sort of
workflow of developing a drug is a
common kind of approach is to First find
a Target that is oh we found out that if
you get this kind of disease this kind
of thing happens in this type of cell
this type of receptor on some cell
surface is modified in this way okay
that's a Target that's a thing we can go
and do something about
um with a drug potentially then you have
to actually design the drug that will
hit that that will attach to that Target
and often that's a question of making a
thing which has the right shape to bind
to that particular thing like puzzle
pieces fitting together and there was a
big enthusiasm about 25 years ago maybe
now for so-called rational drug design
of just like you make a computer design
system and you'd like drawing your
molecules and then we're going to make
it this way it didn't really pan out at
the time maybe now it will become more
possible again and what tended to happen
instead is that people would do the kind
of much more empirical thing of saying
we've got this target we know what we
want the drug to do now we've got this
library of 5 million substances that we
got from all over the place you know we
found them from the bark of the tree in
the Amazon jungle we found them from
this kind of insect we've manufactured
them in this way let's just try you know
a gazillion of those substances and just
see if any of them actually are useful
for this particular Target and that had
been has been kind of a sort of
combinatorial chemistry well that's who
that that's there are ways to do that
even in a more sort of structured way
not so much just trying the library but
actually constructing molecules but but
that's some
that's been a sort of a typical way to
do things whether it's possible to
actually sort of design from scratch
that looks now to be somewhat more
realistic only very recently though now
when it comes to bigger things of you
know can we make an organism that um uh
will I don't know uh
um I I don't know the famous example
from science fiction the movie Blade
Runner this the original version of it
um I think it it opens with this um uh
scene of this of this um character who
is a uh a biological designer so to
speak who has all these little creatures
that you know one of them opens the door
of his apartment one of them you know
starts making coffee or something and
and it's kind of a vision of uh biology
as technology so to speak actually back
in the in the 1970s even
um you know I remember people talking
about uh you know technology and
electronics they're never going to make
it what's really going to happen is
biology and one's going to be able to
make sort of designer organisms and
they're going to be the way to make
things happen mostly that's not how it's
played out there are a few exceptions
for example the uh when genetic
engineering was first coming online in
the 1980s 1970 his 1980s one of the big
things that started happening was the
ability to kind of uh piggyback on top
of things like E coli very common
bacterium
um and re instead of having it make the
proteins it usually makes have it make
the proteins you want it to make and
that became a very common way to make
drugs for example insulin is often made
that way where you just have given an
insulin Gene toward this bacterium and
you've got a giant vat of this bacterium
and um it's uh
um and uh but instead of it making the
stuff that it you normally makes to just
be the bacterium it's got this extra
Gene in it that is making a substance
that is useful to us a drug or a a
biological agent that's useful to us
so that's a case where we did sort of
piggyback on biology now of course in in
in times past uh you know a lot of
processes for making food and things
have been and and other materials for
that matter have been again sort of
piggybacked on biology but that's a more
direct version of that but I don't think
at the level of having a an organism a
little creepy crawly you know ant-like
thing or something we're not there yet
not even close to being able to make you
know the designer ant that can um you
know what one might imagine a situation
where instead of you know sending the um
uh you know where you could say oh we've
got this problem you know we need to
clean up this mess that was made by
something or other you know nuclear
reactor mess or a mess made by some
chemical spell or whatever else let's
send in the artificial ants that have
been designer created to be suitable to
deal with that we're not to the point
where we can do that right now you know
we're still to the point where at best
we can send in the robot so to speak
with uh with the right kind of um uh
apparatus to deal with it
let's see
um
the question here from uh
uh
Lube
um could we build robots out of random
proteins good question
um
you know
the problem is
we don't really know how to do
sort of engineering
at
a molecular scale
the only you know we biological
organisms are pretty good at doing
engineering at a molecular scale and you
know we have all these mechanisms of
molecules interlocking with each other
and and doing things and so on that's
all happening at a very molecular scale
and we have managed to sort of
orchestrate that that's what we
biological organisms manage to do we
don't know how to do that yet
technologically
um we you know we can make things when
we make things technologically like a
microprocessor microprocessors have
you know they're made by essentially
photolithography they're made by taking
you know big chunk of silicon that's
been made very pure and then what you're
essentially doing is taking a photograph
of the whole pattern of wires that you
want in your chip and you're projecting
that photograph down you know using
ultraviolet light and x-rays and all
kinds of things like that to a very very
tiny region in Silicon and you're you're
just straight etching away the places
where light falls or doesn't fall or
whatever and that's the way that you're
making this kind of giant road map of
where all the wires are going to go it's
very solid based stuff it's very much
you've got a solid thing it's a it's a
crystal of silicon and you're etching
away the places where you want the wires
to be and that's how you make the giant
kind of uh giant circuit that is going
to be our microprocessor and one nice
feature of that is once you made it it
is that way that's it you know it's it's
you you you
etched it out you get multiple layers of
etching you put different dope events in
it and things but it's just you're kind
of making it as as a solid kind of thing
in biology
we actually we often at least think that
that's not how things are working at all
that it's more liquid phase where there
are a bunch of molecules that they're
moving around they're bumping into each
other they're arranging themselves in a
particular orientation that's how
they're operating I think it's becoming
clearer that there are more features of
biology that are more solid-like than we
think so for example the cell membrane
around every one of our cells very
similar to the lipid nanoparticle
membrane that was used for the MRNA
vaccines for for example but it's a that
is essentially like a crystal it's not
it's it's a it's a single layer but it's
got a bunch of of uh of little molecules
that are all arranged in a very rigid
array
um and you know when we look at the
surface of a biological cell it's
basically that that lipid bilayer thing
of a bunch of these sort of rod-like
molecules all stuck together in this
hexagonal array I think
um and it's um and then
uh there are things poking through there
are all kinds of different sorts of
essentially sensors and actuators on
cells there are molecules that sense
things that are molecules that deliver
material they're molecules that pull
material in there are all kinds of
little tubes that transport
um the proteins are very common Motif
and a protein as uh what's an alpha
Helix which is a place where the amino
acids have got in a helical shape and
there's enough sort of of a gap inside
the Helix that you can transport
um things like ions but you know things
like sodium atoms and things like that
through that Alpha Helix to transport
them in and out of a cell and and that's
a mechanism that biology uses a bunch
but biology is full of these kinds of of
mechanisms like that and I think the uh
sort of the the challenge of making a
making technology out of biological
components is is really the
orchestration of all these different
pieces
um you know I think it it's uh uh
biology you know a biological cell has
got this you know rigid outside more
like well it's it's floppy but it's it's
locally rigid and it has all kinds of
things sticking through it and it's got
all these mechanisms and within a cell
it's increasingly clear that there are
these you know little fibers that
transport materials and it's all pretty
organized it's all kind of very
factory-like it's much more Factory like
the one might have thought it's much
less like a chemical plant because a
typical chemical plant things are
operating in a liquid phase or a gas
phase liquid phases the sort of favorite
phase to get chemical reactions to
happen in because in a gas there are
molecules bouncing around but there just
aren't that many molecules and so they
don't you know they don't react that
much in in a solid the molecules are
just locked in place so they don't get
to you know if two molecules really
needed to meet to have a chemical
reaction they probably won't be because
they're stuck in the solid far apart but
liquid things are sort of really moving
around and that's sort of the best place
to get to get chemical reactions to
happen that's why you know when it comes
to you know airport security and so on
it's like don't don't take too much
liquid because liquid is what you need
to make some some nasty chemical
reaction that that um that one doesn't
want but uh you know if it's just solid
you can't you can't do it in the same
way
um so you know it has been the case that
once thought uh I would have thought
that a lot of what's going on in biology
is liquid phase chemical processes but I
think that may not be really correct and
that it's more machine based it's sort
of mechanoidal type stuff where you have
these um
uh these things that are like tiny
pieces of more like solid things and in
fact my own guess right now is that when
when it comes to sort of the the bird
versus plane kind of issue of you know
you want to make a thing that sort of
has the the advantages of biology
um but is made with technological
components just like you want the
advantage of biology being able to fly
through the air but you want to make it
out of technological components like
aluminum rather than out of feathers and
things
um and uh so you know my own guess right
now very recent guess actually is that
the the way to think about this is to
imagine making things that are very much
like microprocessor chips out of solid
objects but that have all sorts of tubes
and wires effectively more so tubes
because if you're interested in actually
doing things with molecules you can
imagine something so in a microprocessor
what you're basically moving around is
electricity you're moving electrons
around and in those in those wires
you're arranging for the electrons to go
you know a voltage will push the
electrons from one one end of a wire to
the other and you're arranging to sort
of herd the electrons around your
microprocessor so the the thing that I'm
kind of suspecting is that you can make
kind of little tubes in the your sort of
generalized nanotech microprocessor that
are capable not of having electrons
herded through them but having protons
for example hydrogen nuclei or having
other kinds of molecules sort of herded
through them and that that becomes
something which is kind of the
technological version of something like
biology in the sense it's making use of
molecules making use of chemical call
types of things but it's doing that in a
in sort of in a way that we can
technologically control anyway that
that's my my current guess for for how
to think about that kind of thing and
and I'm I'm sort of uh uh you know be
quite wonderful if we could figure out
how to make a collection of designer
proteins for example here's is an
interesting exercise you know we got
something like Lego we got you know
these bricks you can make all kinds of
interesting things out of it
um you uh and this is a little bit
related again to the general purpose
robotics question of What kinds of
primitive elements do you need to make a
physical an interesting physical device
but but you know just going for the Lego
thing for a moment
um an interesting question is whether
with sort of modern approaches to sort
of Designing a protein of the shape you
want so to speak whether you can
actually construct something where you
can make a good construction kit people
have tried to do this a little bit I
mean they certainly have been some
rhetoric around making sort of
biological or bricks so to speak but I
hasn't I think gotten that far and it
ends up becoming sort of degenerating
back down to essentially pure genetic
engineering of you know put this
particular uh you know Gene that makes a
particular protein into this particular
organism
so
the question I think really now is you
know if we can make a protein that's any
shape and by the way it's not totally
obvious we can make a protein that's any
shape that's another thing that will be
interesting to figure out is given the
raw material of proteins amino acids
whatever else we know there are certain
motifs that are pretty common like Alpha
helices like beta sheets like other
kinds of kinds of shapes but is it in
fact the case that protein stuff amino
acid sequences how General are the
shapes that those can make what is the
space of possible shapes they can make
it's probably quite broad that
antibodies make use of the breadth of
those shapes but I don't know to what
extent you know if you said I wanted to
make a uh well I was going to say I want
to make an icosahedron you know a
20-sided platonic solid 20 face platonic
solid and I was like maybe that's hard
and I realized no that's what uh
um uh viral capsids are often that shape
um that's actually something quite easy
to make out of protein it turns out but
so if you pick a shape uh it's an
interesting question what shapes are
easy and hard to make out of poaching I
I don't know the answer to that and you
know to what extent if you were to make
a construction kit where you know for
example could you make things that
really are like Lego bricks with little
you know little uh uh cylindrical things
that fit onto other things I don't know
I I suspect the answer to that is you
could make that
so you know that that's a question of in
terms of making things out of protein
but yeah I think it's a actually it's
kind of an interesting idea
um to do that I'm not uh you know to to
make proteins that are the right
building block shapes to be able to
build things up to to um to appropriate
size
um
of course then there's still the
question even if you've got those
proteins how do you actually get them to
assemble to the right to the right shape
now something like a crystal the way a
crystal grows is it's got that solid
surface a very organized molecules that
are arranged in the array that they're
arranged in in the Crystal and then
there's maybe a liquid molecules and a
liquid floating around and then whenever
they hit the crystal in the right place
they'll stick on and then the crystal
will progressively grow but they'll only
stick in such a way as to be arranged in
the correct grid to make the to you know
to grow that perfect Crystal so to speak
um and so the the question then is if
you're trying to make sort of a more
complicated kind of structure that isn't
just a regular periodic Crystal
um you know how would you grow that I
looked at that actually a bit and this
question of sort of What kinds of things
can you grow by having essentially tiles
that you lay down and which sort of
arrange themselves just According to
some matching rules for tiles my guess
is and I know theoretically that it's
possible to sort of make more or less
arbitrary patterns that way but actually
coming up with tiles that do that and
coming up with proteins that would sort
of naturally do it and where the protein
would with reasonable probability stick
on in the right way and so on
um that's something that is not yet to
the point that we know how to do it
uh
damp is commenting about Eric drexler's
work uh sort of the the Namer of
nanotechnology and um person who in the
1980s
um did a whole bunch of work on thinking
about how to make molecular scale
machines I think
um my feeling is that well unfortunately
that whole field
for reasons of essentially scientific
politics kind of crashed on the rocks
very unfortunately
um I mean but the it's interesting to
look at the kind of um
uh sort of the the concept some aspects
of which I think were on the right track
and some I'm not sure were so much on
the right track
kind of the idea was let's take
Machinery cogs gears levers
things like that let's take mechanical
machinery and let's try to shrink it
down to molecular scale it's not obvious
how you do that because a lot of issues
about forces and and uh you know
trade-offs between the strength of
things and the force they can exert and
so on are very different when your
molecular scale than when you're made
out of giant pieces of steel or
something
um but that that was a thing that Eric
Drexel studied a lot was what are the
trade-offs when you really shrink things
down and the answers were pretty
interesting and I think the conclusion
from that was yes you really can make
shrunken pieces of machinery
now the next question is is that really
the best way to make functionality that
you want out of molecules some of that
Machinery uh you know in in some cases
in biology we see Machinery being used
you know there are molecular Motors
where you're turning a flagellum to make
a bacterium swim so to speak things like
that there are things which look very
you know mechanical engineering
machine-like in biology there's also a
lot that doesn't look that way and so
the question is if you're trying to
achieve certain functionality is the
right way to do it to go to the sort of
the steam engine phase of of human
technological development to go to the
mechanical devices and look to sort of
shrink those down to molecular scale or
is the right thing to do to say let's
imagine let's figure out what
functionality we're trying to achieve
and then perhaps use other Primitives
which aren't the things that we know
from Gears and levers and so on but are
quite different shapes quite different
forms quite different mechanisms which
happen to be convenient to implement
with molecules I have to say that my own
work on um uh on kind of uh the ubiquity
of universal computation the fact that
this idea I call the principle of
computational equivalence this idea that
out of all kinds of stuff you can make
sophisticated computational devices you
can make it you don't need to have the
carefully designed microprocessor to be
able to make something that computes you
can make computation out of all sorts of
different raw materials and that idea
gives one the suggestion that perhaps
you don't need to take what we already
know on the scale of you know levers and
and gears and so on and shrink it down
that's not the only way to make useful
functionality useful technological
functionality instead you might just be
able to take the stuff that naturally
exists on a molecular scale and figure
out how to essentially write software
that will make that stuff up operate in
a way that that does something useful
for us and I tend to favor that approach
and now I I have to say that that I have
been thinking in recent times that one
really has to Think Through what does it
mean to do a computation in liquid phase
chemical reactions things like that I
don't know completely the answer to that
although I do suspect that there have
been some things where the usual way
that we think about doing a computation
you ask a question two plus two what is
it crunch crunch crunch we compute it
the answer is four
I think when you've got molecules
bouncing around a liquid and the
molecules are are interacting in
complicated ways it's much less a
molecules go in crunch crunch crunch
result comes out there's a more
complicated way in which sort of the
computational process is represented and
my guess is that there's kind of a whole
missing branch of chemistry that has to
do with understanding not just how many
of what kind of molecule come out on a
chemical reaction but more what is the
kind of whole dance that individual
molecules take on you know molecule a
meets molecule B then they go off and
they meet other molecules later on that
very molecule meets that other molecule
again but the the having had different
environmental experiences so to speak
that's not something that's accounted
for in chemistry in chemistry normally
you're just saying there's this number
of such and such a kind of molecule this
number of that kind of molecule every
molecule of a given kind is sort of the
same as every other molecule of that
kind it's not like each one has a sort
of personal name and has had a sort of
personal history in the chemical
reaction I think what we see in biology
and molecular biology may make much more
use of you know every molecule has had
its own personal history so to speak and
it matters which individual molecule it
is that's something which at the scale
that we usually operate in in chemistry
and chemical engineering and so on
absolutely invisible to us uh you know
the scale that we usually operate we're
just dealing with with uh you know big
Vats of chemicals and so on or even if
it's much smaller than that it's still
you know trillions of molecules and so
on not the individual story of a
particular molecule now of course those
individual stories can aggregate up and
a trillion molecules can be having those
individual stories but it can matter
that they have particular stories and it
isn't just a question of how many
molecules do this or that so I I think
the um
I mean I think there is ultimately
immense promise to making a sort of
molecular scale uh technology uh in a
sense chemistry has been our approach to
molecular scale technology in the past
but I think it's a very coarse approach
relative to what's possible I think that
um uh the uh you know if you say well
what's the use of molecular scale
technology one thing is you probably can
do things faster smaller better you know
cheaper lower power all this kind of
thing by shrinking things down and you
know just having a few atoms do that
rather than having a giant you know arm
made of of a trillion trillion atoms
doing it
um but I think probably the thing for us
selfish humans so to speak that's
probably the most important is that
because we are made from molecular scale
technology effectively or molecular
scale biology the interface to us is
going to be conveniently done with
molecular scale Machinery that is if we
want to do something where we see say we
want to replace some particular piece of
some organ or we want to do something
that interfaces with some parts of
brains or hearts or livers or whatever
else it's going to be something where we
really need to go down to that molecular
scale and have the ability to make
Machinery on a molecular scale to be a
good fit to interface with us I mean we
could say you know it's we we could
imagine making technology where uh you
know it's it's technology has to be made
so that humans can actually use it
that's sort of what the point of
technology is I mean we could imagine a
technology where it just uh you know
interesting things happen and these
liquids that are floating around but you
know humans can't control what goes on
and so it's not very useful to us
let's see maybe one or two more
questions here and then I should um
wrap up let's see
um
let's comment um
about nanotechnology was talking about
Universal assemblers who just mentioned
what those are and why that's
interesting
the the question is
uh could you make any molecule could you
just say I'm going to type in some code
and I'm going to have this all these
arms moving around these little tiny
molecular scale tips and so on and I'm
just going to make a molecule
and we know how to do that for proteins
we know how to do that when the
components are amino acids these fairly
you know collections of tens of atoms
and so on that are amino acids and we're
sort of connecting them together in a
line we know how to make essentially any
molecule that can be made of amino acids
but now we can ask the question can you
make any molecule made of anything
and people were very interested for a
while in making molecules just out of
carbon atoms and people tried to make I
think one of the one of the achievements
was a molecule called dogosine which was
kind of a carbon atom you know carbon
atoms arranged sort of in the shape of a
of an idealized dog
um I think and then when Buckyballs were
discovered a particular sort of the
soccer ball configuration of carbon
atoms
um that was an example of one of these
kinds of weird shapes made of carbon
atoms but it's a question could you make
a machine that would just churn out
different structures made from carbon
atoms what's happened in practice is
there were you know what was originally
known was diamond and graphite are two
sort of forms of carbon but then
Buckyballs were discovered which is this
this actually exists even in soot but it
wasn't recognized there
um these these these different sort of
cage shapes then graphene which is uh
kind of a a like a tiny tube made from
the kind of thing that makes graphite
but it's it's rolled up in a tube or
sheets of that
um things like this those are kind of
different shapes of of made from carbon
atoms and some of those things like
graphene is very strong has good
electrical connectivity properties
things like that so that's an
interesting in kind of material to make
things out of but you can also ask the
question could you just make an
arbitrary thing with an arbitrary shape
just out of carbon atoms nobody knows
how to do that right now the only ways
we have to make shapes like that are
through chemical reactions so
essentially what we're doing is we have
kind of like if you had um
I'm trying to make something but the the
uh you know you you just had components
that were really very big you didn't get
to ever have that little finger that's
poking at something that little micro
manipulation thing that's just moving
the one piece around instead you've got
this great big sort of robot hand or
something that's that has to sort of uh
bash at things and hope that the little
piece that was supposed to go into that
little hole will successfully be pushed
into the little hole when you're bashing
it with this really big unwieldy hand
and chemistry in a sense is that kind of
story you've got you know you've got
limited set of things you can do you've
got these molecules they're floating
around like in a liquid you say this
molecule will attach in this place it's
pretty common thing to say I want this
particular piece of this molecule to
attach in this particular way in order
to make that happen I'll add a
protecting group that will prevent the
other part of the molecule from that
part of the molecule from being affected
when I affect the other part of the
molecule and then at the right moment in
the comical reaction I'll do something
which will pull off the protecting group
and then it'll sort of expose this thing
which I can then operate on in this way
it's a very it's a very challenging
thing to do chemical synthesis and it's
designing chemical synthesis is an art
form and it's something where the
typical modern chemical synthesis is
maybe 25 maybe 30 steps long
um and it you know longer than that is
really not doable yet
um and but it's a very much a coarse
kind of thing where you're bashing
chemicals in this way and that way to
try and get specific things to happen so
the question of can you make a a thing
that's the shape of a I don't know a
uh rhinoceros or something a molecule
the shape of a rhinoceros
um you know that way and the answer is
going to be really hard you've got to
have this piece which is bashing with a
big molecule that's going to sort of try
and carve out the hore and you've got
this thing that's going to carve out the
little tail and you know it's really
hard to do so kind of the concept would
be could you make a universal assembler
which just has this thing where it's
like a little tiny tip for example
that's just going around and knitting
it's just sort of drawing this
rhinoceros molecule and just
constructing it explicitly like that
so that might seem like it's crazy and
very science fiction-like but actually
an atomic Force microscope does do that
on a very small scale it can it can like
pick up individual atoms and do things
with them but it can't do that on sort
of the large on the scale you need for
this and the thing that has has been
believed for Foo 40 50 years now is that
one dash even longer than that even even
John Von Neumann was talking about
things a bit like this although not so
specifically with molecules back in the
19 late 1940s early 1950s
um the this idea of can we make a
universal assembler where we just
program it and then that little tip
moves around and it says okay I'm going
to put a carbon atom here oh I'm going
to go back to my supply of silicon atoms
and I'm going to pick up a silicon atom
and put it here it's kind of like I'll
just make a designer thing it's kind of
like in in science fiction you know it's
it's not uncommon to have sort of the
universal Constructor type thing where
you know you press the button and it
just creates for you the uh you know
mashed potatoes from nothing or
something just by taking the raw
material the atoms you know a bunch of
carbon atoms and oxygen atoms and
nitrogen atoms and so on and just sort
of makes that
um and it's kind of interesting that
when you look at um uh
you know making a protein for example
um or making uh you know a
um a piece of um of DNA you literally do
have bottles of the different kinds of
bases the four different kinds of bases
for example and you're combining them to
make a piece of DNA of a certain kind so
so we're almost to that point but we're
not quite to that point and nobody knows
how to make the mechanics of a universal
assembler and it's a thing where one
might imagine that one day one will make
a universal assembler and then one can
make anything and in particular the
universal assembler can make more
Universal assemblers and so once you
have just one universal assembler you
can kind of make more Universal
assemblers in its image now of course
we've seen that story before because
that's what life has done life made a
living organism and then living
organisms reproduce themselves and made
more living organisms so in a sense the
idea of the universal assembler that
makes Universal assemblers is a repeat
of the idea of life and and that that's
that's sort of a a an ultimate sort of
Holy Grail objective of of
nanotechnology you know I think people
got kind of worried about is if you can
make anything then you can make things
that are you could for example turn
everything into some kind of gray goo
that would just be sort of some
molecular soup that um uh you could you
could just sort of transform all matter
arbitrarily into whatever you want and
things could go wrong and you could turn
all matter on Earth for example into
something something that isn't the way
you want it to be I I think that that
concern is probably a bit overstated I
mean although we can plainly see that
you know molecular scale uh you know the
fact that we have a molecule that's uh
well we have a virus that's got much
more than just a molecule
um that um uh you know and we have you
know the toe total amount of of
covid virus is you know I think I think
you still hold it in your hands it's
it's a it's a tiny amount of virus that
got spread around the earth and that um
when binding to uh uh all sorts of
pieces of us caused all kinds of trouble
so it's not the case that you can't
cause trouble with molecules there's
plenty of ways you can even with fairly
small amounts of molecules you can cause
all kinds of trouble but I kind of I I
suspect that the everything turns into
this kind of Goo is is perhaps an
overstated issue
um
let's see
oh my
well I think maybe one more thing and
then I should uh
should stop and there's a lot of
questions here about physics and
computation and I can I'm very happy to
talk about that I was off on a different
topic here today uh
Arc asks what if every microorganism is
also a macro organism what is a macro
organism well I I suppose I don't quite
know what a macro organism is I other
than something that is bigger and has
lots of cells in it
um and typically when people talk about
microorganisms they're typically talking
about single cell organisms and so on
um I think that um
you know it is an interesting question
when does you know for us we are solidly
built out of trillions of cells uh for
you know a colony of bacteria the cells
are all separate and they're all
floating around separately but
nevertheless there can be communication
between those cells and so on and it's
not totally obvious the extent to which
when do you call when is an organism you
know what what is the boundary of the
organism so to speak as opposed to you
know the ant colony there's each all the
individual ants but they are doing
things in a in a coherent way where
they're communicating using chemical
signals and all sorts of things like
that and you know you could ask about
human society to what extent are the
eight billion of us or something doing
something coherent where we are
operating as a sort of macro macro
organism and so on and yes it's a it's
an interesting question when you know
it's a it's a feature of biology and
actually a feature of the world in
general that well okay so it seems that
there is sort of modular layers where
you know there are organelles inside a
cell there are cells there are there are
organs made of cells there are you know
collections of organs that make an
organism there are collections of
organisms that make you know a whole
herd of organisms there are old species
Etc et cetera et cetera there are these
different levels of organization and it
is an interesting question to what
extent when we see levels of
organization uh to what extent those are
in the eye of the beholder to what
extent we are identifying those and to
what extent we can really make sharp
distinctions about those different
levels you know when we build Technology
and Engineering it's very common to want
to have things be modular in the sense
and why is that useful it's typically
useful because you can say I'm going to
build this module I'm going to have you
know put a lot of effort into building
this module and then I don't have to
worry about how that module Works inside
I can just plug it together with these
other modules and then together I'll
make something that works well and so
you know biology is presumably doing the
same kind of thing it says I I'm going
to make a you know a kidney or something
and it's going to work in whatever way
it works but you can just assume it will
filter blood and that's its large scale
function you don't have to sort of worry
about what's happening inside and you
can kind of uh you know you can kind of
operate organisms on the basis of kind
of just taking that as a modular piece
but so I I don't know I mean the extent
to which
I I kind of imagine this this kind of
notion of the bacterial Army so to speak
and you know to what extent the thing
can operate in a coherent way I think we
generally assume in microbiology that um
uh yeah I think it's generally assumed
that you know if you get infected with
something some microorganisms some
bacterium let's say that every bacterium
is fighting for itself that it isn't the
case that the bacteria you know in your
gut for example they interact by virtue
of the chemicals one bacteria produces
that will affect another bacterium Etc
et cetera et cetera but I don't think
one's imagining that there's some whole
signaling mechanism where the bacteria
are you know sending little radio
signals or something to each other to
all decide oh let's all go do this thing
there's to my knowledge there's no
mechanism known for things like that I
mean they're they're well having said
that there are certainly small molecules
that can get produced by one
microorganism that will affect other
ones but I don't think you know this
concept of uh you know let's let's
command the whole Army to do something I
don't think that's generally viewed to
be what what you know there are
mechanisms for seeing how that happens
um whereas in a in a full organism like
us there are mechanisms by which our
different cells which are typically
arranged in this fairly rigid way
um you know do manage to communicate and
do manage to operate in these sort of
coherent ways to get us to do sort of
the the seemingly coherent things that
we tend to do
all right well lots of interesting
questions thank you very much for all of
that
um and uh we should probably wrap up for
today
um
and uh
um
uh yeah great well thanks for all that
and um
see you another time bye for now